[Música]
en el congreso de Brasil está pendiente
el debate sobre una ley que busca que
las empresas de internet motores de
búsqueda y servicios de mensajería se
hagan responsables por los contenidos en
línea que son considerados como noticias
falsas esto ha encendido las alarmas
entre las compañías tecnológicas que
dicen que esta normativa abriría la
puerta a la censura quien tendrá la
potestad de decidir lo que es una
noticia falsa o no es una discusión que
preocupa a los brasileños y por ello lo
analizamos con vía Barbosa y es
coordinadora de incidencia de reporteros
Sin fronteras para América Latina señora
Barbosa bienvenida directo América
Hola buenos días Muchísimas gracias por
la invitación primero que todo cómo se
garantizará que esta ley no se convierta
en un pretexto para censurar opiniones
divergentes o críticas hacia el gobierno
por ejemplo u otros actores poderosos en
Brasil bueno primero es importante decir
que el esfuerzo que está pasando en
Brasil ahora también está ocurriendo en
varias partes del mundo porque se
entiende que La regulación democrática
de las plataformas de redes sociales es
necesaria para garantizar una mayor
transparencia sobre el funcionamiento de
esas empresas que tiene un impacto
gigante en el flujo de información y
contenidos distribuidos en entorno
digital verdad para garantizar sobre
todo una más grande libertad de
expresión para los usuarios teniendo en
cuenta que hay hoy una opacidad en la
forma en que las plataformas Modern el
contenido recomiendan post eliminan
contenido del área y y a veces bloquean
cuentas hoy en día Todo esto se hace en
base de condiciones de uso y normas
comunitarias definidas individualmente
por estas empresas y que a menudo no
diálo la legislación de los países en
que ellos operan donde las operan
Entonces es importante decir que es una
ley para garantizar más más
transparencia más libertad de expresión
y sobre todo es una ley que quiere traer
justamente principios democráticos para
que esto para que la moderación de
contenido pueda ser hecha por las
empresas de una manera democrática y no
solamente con base en sus términos
propios de usos seguro que no que hay
que garantizar salvaguardas en el
proyecto de ley para que no sea el
gobierno de plantón que va a decir lo
que puede que no se puede publicar en
las redes sociales Esta no es la idea
Por eso que uno de los temas importantes
de la ley es la creación de un organismo
regulador regulatorio independiente como
ya existen muchos países como Estados
Unidos Francia Portugal Canadá Japón que
pueden garantizar la implementación de
la ley de una manera democrática de una
parte garantizar que las empresas puedan
cumplir con su tarea de moderación de
miedos pero que lo hagan a partir de
criterios democráticos y que si no
cumpla la ley pueden ser sancionadas
ahora existe el riesgo de que por
ejemplo estas empresas se sientan
presionadas para ejercer una moderación
excesiva o adaptar sus políticas de
censura para evitar problemas legales
con la justicia Sí por eso lo quiere ir
para esto
propone las empresas no sean
responsables directamente por los
contenidos publicados por los usuarios
esto incluso está previsto en una ley
que ya existe en el Brasil que se llama
Marco civil de la internet que dice que
los usuarios son los responsables por
los contenidos que publican hay todo un
esfuerzo y nosotros esperemos que el
parlamento brasileño no cambie Este
modelo de responsabilidad de las
plataformas para decir que ahí son todas
responsables también por todos los
contenidos publicados por los usuarios
porque de hecho eso se pasa se quedaría
sin un impulso para que ellas
sobremoderen los contenidos de saque
mucho más contenidos de quienes es
necesario y ahí haría sin un riesgo para
libertad de expresión entonces la idea
que el proyecto trae es muy parecido con
una ley que está aprobada y que está
implementación en Europa ahora que se
llama el el digital
La Ley de servicios digitales que dice
que las plataformas tienen un deber de
evaluar sistemáticamente
riesgos sistémicos que es su modo de
funcionamiento trae para las democracias
para los derechos de los niños para la
promoción de los Derechos Humanos Y a
partir de una evaluación sistemática de
esos riesgos que ellos tengan que decir
lo que están haciendo para disminuir ese
riesgo para bajar ese riesgo para que no
se atente contra los Derechos Humanos Sí
hay un cambio en la ley de del régimen
de responsabilidad directo de las
plataformas y que todas las plataformas
pasen a ser responsables por todos los
contenidos de los usuarios ahí sí avería
un impulso para una sobre moderación
pero el proyecto de ley brasileño no
está caminando en este sentido y sí está
caminando de una manera mucho parecido
con que le pasó en Europa en este
momento para que haya solamente
evaluaciones periódicas de los riesgos
sistémicos del funcionamiento de las
plataformas ahora vía Cuáles son las
ventajas y desventajas y cuál es por
ejemplo la posibilidad de que esto un
precedente para que otros países de la
región se muevan hacia normativas
similares
Bueno me parece que
es importantes en el proyecto de ley
además de esta gestión de la moderación
de contenido que hablamos Me parece que
la fiesta de la transparencia es
importante el texto establece por
ejemplo deberes de las plataformas de
publicar informes periódicos con datos
que en general ellas omiten revelar por
ejemplo Cuántos usuarios tienen cada
país Cuántas cuentas han sido eliminadas
de Por qué qué criterios utilizan las
empresas para dirigir los contenidos a
los usuarios algunas de las grandes
plataformas ya tienen informes de
transparencia pero ellos no están
detallados por países porque impiden
conocer de hecho el funcionamiento de
estas empresas otro eje central
importante para libertad de expresión
también tiene que ver si la empresa va a
moderar un contenido publicado por un
usuario es importante que ella pueda
hacerlo tiene que notificar el usuario
explicar Cuáles son las condiciones que
fueron eventualmente violadas y no
limitarse decir por ejemplo que violaron
las normas de la plataforma como ocurre
hoy y permitir mecanismos fáciles y
rápidos de en estas palabras exactamente
deben ver la plataforma respetar la
libertad de expresión de los usuarios
Estos son son mecanismos que nos parecen
importantes y son positivos en el texto
Pero sabemos que como un proyecto en el
parlamento no sabemos cómo termina
entonces hay que dar para que en el
proceso de discusión con los
parlamentarios estas a vanguardias de la
libertad de expresión estén garantizados
hasta la aprobación final de la ley vía
Barbosa Lamento interrumpirla nos quedan
muchas aristas por analizar pero
lamentablemente Se nos acabó el tiempo
ya vendrán otras oportunidades vía
Barbosa coordinadora de incidencia de
reporteros Sin fronteras para América
Latina Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
con el análisis gracias a ustedes y así
termina otro bloque de directo América
pero no se desconecten que a
continuación regresamos con más
[Música]